I made a big mistake that's impossible
are like pudding everybody likes pudding
I screwed up everybody's life are you
gonna be there hurt me just try to
understand you need to tell me what is
going on area right now is Tuesday at
8/7 central hey youtubers is charlie so
we have the actual trailer for episode 2
let's break it down this is episode 2
not like the next four episodes like the
last trailer so we have full-blown
killer frost the other trailer that I
posted includes footage from episodes
two three maybe even episode four but
basically the next couple episodes so
specifically like when you're talking
about flashpoint paradox the title of
this episode is paradox it deals with
all the WTF twists that Barry finds
after he goes back like the
reverse-flash
chuckled Adam and said oh you'll find
out if everything is gonna go back to
normal like he totally knows but doesn't
want to tell Barry he just wants to
gloat knowing what Barry's reactions
gonna be
when he goes back and sees that it's
still complete chaos as if in trying to
walk back saving his mother he was not
able to reset everything to baseline
so you see Caitlin snow manifesting
killer frost powers that answers the
biggest question and that was like the
biggest reason for making this video
because we know there is an episode 7
titled killer frost meaning there's
gonna be some deep killer frost
going down before the big four night
crossover because that's episode 8 the
week after that so you're probably
asking is she going to slowly turn into
this version of killer frost like will
her skin turn blue will her hair turn
white like what's going on how can she
have these powers and not also look like
killer frost I think the idea this
season is to present a more complex
version of the Caitlin snow character
someone who has all that killer frost
stuff swirling around inside her and it
just manifests physically so she's not
able to ignore it like she can suppress
certain parts of her personality like
she seems like this really happy bubbly
character
who's a child doctor in the first
episode like the sweetest thing ever but
like season 2 killer frost all of that
stuff is inside of her it's not like
she's a completely different person it's
just that when characters have inside
thoughts like mate you know maybe they
think something that's not very nice or
do they want to say something really
crazy but they hold back it just the
killer frost doesn't hold back it's kind
of like the difference between Harleen
Quinzel and Harley Quinn yet you know
one that's like a doctor the other one
who's just like the purest expression of
freedom like I'm gonna say whatever I
want do whatever I want
who cares what everybody thinks about me
so Caitlin snow is kind of like the dr.
Harleen Quinzel version of killer frost
killer frost is just like the fullest
expression of all of Caitlin snows
emotions the inside voices turned into
outside voices so I wouldn't be
surprised if she stays looking like this
for most of the season but at various
points like you see parts of her skin
turned blue just a little bit so maybe
if she loses her then she'll turn
completely blue but I don't think that
they would tease this and not give us
like full-blown killer Frost's at least
once during the season but let me know
in the comments what do you think
they're gonna do with this do you think
they're gonna actually turn her into
blue skin killer frost or is she just
gonna learn to control it by the end of
the season so the other big thing in
this is that we see Barry travelling
through time but like Jay Garrick's hand
reaches and grabs him it looks like Jay
Garrick catches him trying to go back
and fix it yet another time and it's
just like hard pass kid you need to pump
the brakes on all this derping across
space and time because you were making
things worse every time you go back so
he has that speech was like what kind of
here are you gonna be from the reaction
that Barry has to Jay in the trailer it
seems like this is the first time he
runs into him during the season like oh
my god I didn't expect to see you when I
was going back in time yet again to try
and fix everything so now it seems like
everybody is pissed off at Barry like
even iris in the trailer when he goes
back to the new timeline like the most
recently created timeline
iris is like you need to tell me what
the hell is going on because he's still
freaking out like you see Cisco and the
survivor support group so you know maybe
all their adventures together really
messed Cisco up in Barry wasn't that
good of a friend to him whatever happen
they don't seem very close in this
timeline iris and Joe are still on the
outs we don't really know what's up with
Wally and Jesse because we've seen that
other trailer so we know they all come
back so it seems like everybody kind of
slowly comes back together but the
paradox title of the episode in the
stuff that Jay is talking about with
Barry about not taking a do-over every
single time he messes up is just
learning to live with things even if it
doesn't seem like a perfect situation
I mean unlikely really like the concept
of time paradox I talked about this in
the other video but it's just like
creating situations that seem very
contradictory like I saved my mother so
all the stuff that happened because a
flashpoint should be a race now or the
contradiction that Caitlin snow not a
metahuman as detected by earth -
Harrison wells during season two is
suddenly a metahuman now so just to make
some more killer frost puns this is just
the tip of the flashpoint paradox
iceberg so it's only gonna get crazier
from here I'm so excited about this
season they have so many characters so
thankfully like all the stuff that I
thought was coming in episode 2 isn't
getting rolled out - like the next
couple of episodes so if you thought it
was weird that they were gonna roll out
like mirror master top captain cold the
rogue wore all that stuff in the second
episode Jessie quick coming back that's
gonna be spread out over the first
couple episodes so as much as I really
like seeing step forward it's a lot
easier like when they released trailers
for the next episode not the next like
three or four episodes and then just
label it like a really opaque way be the
way new footage is always awesome it's
New York Comic Con now so next up I'll
be posting new Walking Dead be sure to
subscribe to get it
it should be up in a couple hours wait
you guys wait for that to post you can
click here to watch that Iron Fist
trailer again and you can click here for
that legends of tomorrow just a society
4 night crossover trailer thank you so
much for watching everybody let's high
five I'll see you guys tonight